hey I'm Charles Milton hi I'm Alexander
Ludwig and we are from the cast of bad
boys for life the musical the musical
and we're here with thirst tweets I just
saw Charles Melton in the street and I'm
sure I would like to thank that guys for
putting us on the same planet at the
same time you're welcome yeah that's my
other Twitter account there not a day
goes by when I don't think of Kato from
longer games thanks Marvin I don't know
why everyone seems to think Michelangelo
is the greatest sculptor of all time
when he played no part in the creation
of Charles Milton's face sent tweet
that's actually really sweet sometimes I
forget oh how does I forget why I'm
attracted to men but then I remember
Alexander Lily's arms I thought it said
sometimes I forget why I'm attracted to
elevator load away I was like why do you
guys everyone's talking about cole
sprouse in KJ Apple but Charles Melton
aka Reggie is a snack throw face
he's a snack gosh darn it Alexander
Ludwig please punch me in the face -
stop being so perfect it's not okay I
swear to you I'm not perfect I'm very
far from it we want to why I know
there's something to see if I get I
don't want to read about myself I would
tie Charles Milton up bend him over and
do the naughtiest dirtiest things
possible not the first time I've ever
actually he says hi just popping in to
say that I would definitely have sex
cause bill and I would definitely die
doing it that's just as dark and also
wonderful Alexander Ludwig is flawless
his hair his body his smile his dick it
actually says I can't blame his heart
his armpits his eyes his muscles
everything all right
I don't even really like chocolate but
God knows I'd lick chocolate author
Alexander litter whose body any day now
the real question is what part of the
body well if you got that person that
other person probably your armpit sir
anyways Charles Milton from Riverdale is
so [ __ ] hot and I want to eat his
dick for breakfast that is all I'm in a
steady
now by Jesus I want Charles Melton to
wreck my mucous membrane this is just a
poet right there
she must be pre-med I just watched to go
with me to see Alexander literally choke
a guy with his legs do me next daddy
what wait you chose a guy with your legs
yeah but like not sexually I didn't
think it was I come at the sound of
Alexander Ludwig's name
honestly I told Martin to stop writing
these and sit on my face oh that's very
sweet I would let Alexander Ludwig use
my face to draw off his balls oh my god
why no one tell me Charles Milton finest
oh I thought is gonna sell about my dick
or me getting all the dick ones man
child's melting more like Charles and
let me melt on your tits I want to keep
that send it to my mom I'd let Alexander
Ludwig spit in my mouth you trashy
trashy little fox it's my buddy from
high school Charles Milton could stop on
my throat any damn day that's what kind
of scenes are you doing the Riverdale
there I want Charles Bolton to choke me
pass it on
thank you for your support and your kind
words
thanks for the thirst week
[Music]
[Music]